che cazzo di capelli c'ho oggi Vabbè che
bello Ma che belli i capelli che c'ho
oggi brava Mi sto piacendo sono molto
belli vado così a un matrimonio
probabilmente secondo me perché mi sono
alzato neanche con gli insetticida mi si
mettono a posto Bella a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video io sono
Favij Oggi sono su One night at freddy's
ma che gioia incredibile Guarda che gira
cazzo giri è una cosa meravigliosa
ragazzi Appena ho scoperto che hanno
fatto il 2 proprio ho fatto salti di
gioia per tutta la casa infatti non so
se si vede la mia felicità in faccia eh
Bene cominciamo a parte gli scherzi Ma
com'è che hanno fatto anche un due di un
Survival 27 ok Vabbè devo sopravvivere
entro le 6 vabbè Questo lo sappiamo Ma
che bello che è ragazzi meraviglioso e
parecchio carino no veramente Ah che
figo ci sono le [ __ ] un cazzo perché
tanto sarà bruttissimo Comunque la
partenza ragazzi tutt'altro che
meravigliosa proprio bella Qua c'è
scritto muori ma tua madre eh devo
capire un attimo Allora cosa devo fare
qui a parte che c'è sta musica che la
possono potete togliere perché mi chiami
girano le palle eh
[Musica]
Ok cosa cazzo è successo raga bene Eh
devo Non ho capito un gran calmi calmi
che non sto capendo Cosa devo fare
allora in giro c'è Ciao flampty come
stai Io sono qui ok Devo andare Ah c'è
anche altro tizio che cazzo è successo
Ah si scarica il computer Ma seriamente
Cioè non sto capendo un cazzo allora si
scarica il computer quindi posso vedere
le cose piano però c'è il tizio che sta
andando a sinistra [ __ ] La [ __ ] La
[ __ ] proprio che [ __ ] E vabbè dai
dai è che Che cribbio qualcos'altro
magari Mandatemi anche Gesù Già che ci
siete non lo so bellissimo complimenti
Ho capito tutto Comunque ragazzi Fatemi
capire un attimo perché non ho capito
una mazza di niente di quello che ho
visto Ah c'è il gufo e questa abbiamo
capito che non è non è molto amichevole
Vabbè poi ci sono sti occhi che c'erano
anche nell'altro che non ho capito il
portatile si scarica in 0,3 secondi
quindi meraviglioso cioè proprio
semplice da fare e c'è flauti che fa il
[ __ ] che mi arriva davanti ogni
tanto e devo spegnere le luci qua Che
bello che sei Luigi può far scaricare il
computer in poche parole perché sennò
c'ho nel culo si è svegliato il gufo
quando si sveglia il gufo son cazzi
Questo l'ho capito ma io non posso stare
con le luci spente scusate
giorno ok È una roba cos'è incoming Cosa
cazzo era quella roba calmi piano piano
non ho capito niente cosa sta succedendo
oddio oddio Ciao Franci tutto a posto
Tutto a posto un cazzo Aiuto no no no no
no no Raga vi prego vi prego non ho
capito Non sto capendo è difficile è più
difficile dell'altro Che cazzo fai No il
gufo Ragà il gufo no no no no no tanto
sbatte
state facendo amicizia col Gufo stronzi
è più figo di five Nights at freddy's
non lo so perché regà cos'è No allora
redman di merda tu devi toglierti ma non
posso rimanere sempre così Ah no perché
sennò il gufo mi fa il culo Perfetto Ok
ho capito no no no no no no quanto sei
bello zio No vabbè ma vacci da un
dentista Eh prima o poi te lo consiglio
Perfetto Mi stava ascoltando ragazzi
perché mi è spuntata una chiazza nera
sul muro che cazzo succede Eh secondo
solo che capisco cosa cazzo è quella
roba raga aiuto cosa sta succedendo
calmi calmi tutti Cosa cazzo vuol dire
pazienza 500 sta scendendo raga vuol
dire che mi salta addosso Sto stronzo
Fatemi capire ragazzi oh oh
[ __ ] vacca [ __ ] lo sapete che cazzo
guardi bellissima una bellissima un
cazzo non ti invita la mia festa inutile
che fai il pagliaccio No è stato è stato
figo è stato veramente figo
probabilmente non ho capito un cazzo Ma
cosa facciamo proprio il contatore Cioè
mi devo accorgere Io di quando
ho trovato chi ha che botta scassato
tutto raga' ho scassato gli mortacci del
Gufo di merda Beh non si sono Allora con
Five Nights at freddy's mi è successo di
di scassarle Ringraziando Dio sono
ancora intatto va bene così benissimo
Ragazzi ma quanto è figo sto gioco da 1
a 200 credo due o tre la cosa difficile
raga è che ci sono mille Ah che bello
questo guancette che mandate le mangio
il computer serve soltanto per guardare
si stronzi e basta perché sennò col
cazzo Intanto che cosa me ne frega non
capisco quando arrivano
Adesso l'ho capito però l'ho fatto in
tempo quindi Ok ma convinto che mi
spunta quello che sembra marshmallow
convintissimo proprio dove cazzo è Ah
sono qua tutti e due perfetto No basta
redman Il bello è che mi chiede se vuole
se vuole che mi spunti e devo solo
cliccare e cancello Cioè non è difficile
evitarlo credo eh Poi magari muoio 20
volte però ok Ci siete ragazzi cioè che
figo che sei No no no raga Da dove
arriva Ah boh per te l'ho aperto cazzo
l'ho aperto la pentola Non volevo Ho
sbagliato ho sbagliato io non so se si
era capito ma sono un [ __ ] ho avuto
un momento di panico perché non avevo
capito quale delle due fosse Ovviamente
ho azzeccato quella sbagliata ma è ovvio
quindi va beh è strano sto già è proprio
strana A parte che c'è Freddy sul muro a
caso Non l'avevo nemmeno notato Perché
minchia il gioco è talmente incasinato
che non ti fa vedere un cazzo ragazzi
cioè no no
Ho detto no che cazzo è flamty raga è
impossibile Ah eccolo Minchia non lo
vedevo più fantastico Tra l'altro
bellissimo il quadro dietro che è uguale
e il gufo il gufo Il Gufo di merda Il
Gufo di merda praticamente devo fare
così sempre ricordati sempre a parte
quando si sveglia con lo stronzo del
pagliaccio [ __ ] [ __ ] che caga son
caga cattiva Ah bello le zizze lei mi
dai i [ __ ] Grazie ciao le animazioni
sto gioco Non ho mai visto un Five
Nights on One night con le animazioni
vere di gente che cammina Ah ce la sono
in five Nights at freddy' tipo però ok
No no Fermi Ecco lo sapevo no no no
Minchia mi sono salvato sto gufo dove
dovete uccidere a battetelo cazzo Il
problema è che è geniale 'sto gioco
perché per guardare sto cazzo di gufo
devo tener le luci accese quindi un
macello che poi sto cazzo di computer si
scarica come niente Minchia ma che
Batteria c'ha dei cinesi neanche dei
cinesi guardano Guardalo
sarà infilato tutto nel culo ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta tanto c'è una Coca Cola vuota
perché chi è che si è sgolato la coca
siamo alle 3:00 di notte ragazzi e ce la
sto facendo cosa impossibile nella vita
non ci posso credere manco io dovevo
dire questa cosa vero non Dovevo dirla
Perfetto grazie di ricordarmi ogni volta
che devo starmene zitto perché ehm
Questa è la risposta a redman Dai cazzo
scattate se quattro di notte maledizione
che non ne posso più Mi piace un ansia
Allora il bello è che sto stronzo ti
spunta come niente mentre Fanti almeno
un po' di tempo te lo dà È chiuso è
chiuso è chiuso Ok calmi [ __ ] A posto
Fatto Fatto Sì un attimo però cazzo
troppa roba insieme calmi che mi chiamo
sto capendo più niente ammazzo col
pomodoro che c'ho attaccato al muro te
lo giuro È una roba indecente sto gioco
è una roba veramente in concepito Che
cos'è che ha inventato sta roba cioè
Fatemi capire che problemi mentali ha
per attaccare quello di Winnie the Pooh
che non mi ricordo mai il nome
Ok ok
posso accendere non posso accendere mi
sa che non posso accendere cioè proprio
questa avete anche Gesù nel repertorio
Non lo so mandate anche lui Grazie
proprio non manca solo lui proprio
Grazie mille molto gentili il gufo lo
sapevo è chiusa redman
sono vivo cioè ragazzi sono le cinque ce
lo sto facendo ce la sto facendo Non so
come no no E vabbè adesso che cazzo
minchia la Peluso insetti
Vai via vai via ti giunta lo spruzzo in
faccia ti ammazzo la famiglia pure sono
le 5 ragazzi sono le 5 forza scattate se
sei di merda per l'amor di Dio no no no
no no
Madonna cosa ha fatto non lo so
neanch'io
T'ammazzo ti ammazzo se perdo ti ammazzo
dai dai dai dai
perché no perché non scattano Ste merda
di 6 forza
no no no no no no no non riesco a
premere perché non scattano le sei sono
due ore che gioco dai dai
ti prego Sono due ore che sono le 5 Ti
prego
[Musica]
ci credo non ci sto credendo non ci sto
credendo Ho vinto Ho vinto a One night
Atlantide 2 al primo episodio non ci sto
che non è possibile ragazzi ce l'ho
fatta in una maniera incredibile va bene
così Sono contento sono soddisfatto Tu
puoi morire cos'è hard boiled Mod cioè è
una roba Oh mio Dio Eh vabbè che cazzo
succede troppa roba insieme Ah è proprio
così frenetico dall'inizio è
meraviglioso ragazzi lo faccio la
prossima volta perché non ho Non ce la
farò mai nella vita ma che cazzo è No
vabbè troppa roba raga è impossibile
questo è veramente [ __ ]
la vacca anche se cuffie la uccise oggi
le uccise Vabbè Ragazzi è stato bello
così io per oggi concludo che mi son non
voglio finire in Vittoria e basta perché
non ce la posso fare quindi ragazzi
Vittoria è il primo episodio non è mai
successo farò anche lard boiled ma
questa cosa qua però non adesso perché
voglio vivere ancora cioè proprio c'ho
questa voglia di vivere quindi lascio
perdere Spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come al solito Se il video Vi è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di Facebook che
condividono il video trovate nella
descrizione sotto se siete riusciti
scrivete noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazzi
[Musica]